We will now consider an example
that illustrates the
difference between the notion
of independence of a
collection of events and
the notion of pairwise
independence within
that collection.
The model is simple.
We have a fair coin which
we flip twice.
So at each flip, there
is probability 1/2
of obtaining heads.
Furthermore, we assume that the
two flips are independent
of each other.
Let H1 be the event that the
first coin toss resulted in
heads, which corresponds to this
event in this diagram.
Let H2 be the event that the
second toss resulted in heads,
which is this event
in the diagram--
the two ways that we can have
the second toss being heads.
Now, we're assuming that the
tosses are independent.
So the event heads-heads has a
probability which is equal to
the probability that the first
toss resulted in heads--
that's 1/2--
times the probability that the
second toss resulted in heads,
which is 1/2.
So the product is 1/4.
We have probability 1/4
for this outcome.
Now, the total probability of
event H1 is 1/2, which means
that the probability of what
remains should be 1/4, so that
the sum of these two
numbers is 1/2.
By the same argument, the
probability of this outcome,
tails-heads , should be 1/4.
We have a total of 3/4.
So what's left is 1/4.
And that's going to be the
probability of the outcome
tails-tails .
Let us now introduce a new
event, namely the event that
the two tosses had
the same result.
So this is the event that we
obtain either heads heads or
tails-tails.
Schematically, event C
corresponds to this blue
region in the diagram.
Is this event C independent
from the events H1 and H2?
Let us first look for pairwise
independence.
Let's look at the probability
that H1 occurs
and C occurs as well.
So the first toss resulted
in heads.
And the two tosses had
the same result.
So this is the same as the
probability of obtaining heads
followed by heads.
And this corresponds to just
this outcome that has
probability 1/4.
How about the product of the
probabilities of H1 and of C?
Is it the same?
Well, the probability
of H1 is 1/2.
And the probability of C--
what is it?
Event C consists of
two outcomes.
Each one of these outcomes
has probability 1/4.
So the total is, again, 1/2.
And therefore, the product of
these probabilities is 1/4.
So we notice that the
probability of the two events
happening is the same as the
product of their individual
probabilities, and therefore,
H1 and C
are independent events.
By the same argument, H2 and C
are going to be independent.
It's a symmetrical situation.
H1 and H2 are also independent
from each other.
So we have all of the conditions
for pairwise
independence.
Let us now check whether
we have independence.
To check for independence, we
need to also look into the
probability of all three events
happening and see
whether it is equal to the
product of the individual
probabilities.
So the probability of all
three events happening--
this is the probability
that H1 occurs and H2
occurs and C occurs.
What is this event?
Heads in the first toss, heads
in the second toss, and the
two tosses are the same--
this happens if and only
if the outcome is
heads followed by heads.
And this has probability 1/4.
On the other hand, if we
calculate the probability of
H1 times the probability of H2
times the probability of C, we
get 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2, which is 1/8.
These two numbers
are different.
And therefore, one of the
conditions that we had for
independence is violated.
So in this example, H1,
H2, and C are pairwise
independent, but they're not
independent in the sense of an
independent collection
of events.
How are we to understand
this intuitively?
If I tell you that event H1
occurred and I ask you for the
conditional probability
of C given that H1
[occurred], what is this?
This is the probability that
we obtain, given that the
first event is heads, the first
result is heads, the
only way that you can have the
two tosses having the same
result is going to be in
the second toss also
resulting in heads.
And since H2 and H1 are
independent, this is just the
probability that we have heads
in the second toss.
And this number is 1/2.
And 1/2 is also the same as the
probability of C. That's
another way of understanding the
independence of H1 and C.
Given that the first toss
resulted in heads, this does
not help you in any way in
guessing whether the two
tosses will have the
same result or not.
The first one was heads, but the
second one could be either
heads or tails with
equal probability.
So event H1 does not carry any
useful information about the
occurrence or non-occurrence of
event C. On the other hand,
if I were to tell you that
both events, H1 and H2,
happened, what would
the conditional
probability of C be?
If both H1 and H2 occurred, then
the results of the two
coin tosses were identical, so
you know that C also occurred.
So this probability
is equal to 1.
And this number, 1, is
different from the
unconditional probability
of C, which is 1/2.
So we have here a situation
where knowledge of H1 having
occurred does not help you in
making a better guess on
whether C is going to occur.
H1 by itself does not carry
any useful information.
But the two events together,
H1 and H2, do carry useful
information about C.
Once you know that H1 and
H2 occurred, then C
is certain to occur.
So your original probability for
C, which was 1/2, now gets
revised to a value of 1.
So H1 and H2 carry information
relevant to C. And therefore,
C is not independent from these
two events collectively.
And we say that events H1.
H2, and C are not independent.